for any fans of pursuit of wonder there
is now a free email newsletter that will
provide updates insights new projects
and product releases special offerings
and anything else pursuit of wonder
related in the future as a thank you
five people who sign up for the
newsletter who can also verify that they
followed the pursuit of wonder instagram
will be randomly selected by the end of
february to receive copies of my two
books and guided writing journal for
free all the relevant links are in the
description below
i woke up face down on the sidewalk i
was in front of my friend alex's
apartment building i felt like i was
dying my head was pounding my body was
aching it was the worst hangover i had
ever felt in my entire life
and i drank a lot
it was a tuesday morning and the streets
were unusually quiet i didn't think much
of it though the only thing i could
think about was my constricted throbbing
heavy liquor inflicted body feeling like
it was dissolving away with my essence
demanding and screaming for my sole
attention to hold on to it
i walked back to my apartment and tried
taking a shower but the water seemed to
almost just go through me i didn't even
feel the wetness
i became so weak and unsettled i
collapsed
i crawled out from the bathroom and into
my bed and tried falling asleep i had
never felt like i needed to sleep
forever as badly as i did in that moment
but i couldn't
it seemed like there was almost a
mechanism blocking me from doing so
i always had a hard time sleeping but
not like that i felt so unbearably tired
yet completely awake like i was drifting
off into another state but was unable to
close my eyes and let go of this one
after giving up and basically just
staring at the ceiling for some obscene
amount of time i called alex to ask
about what had happened the previous
night and then see if he wanted to get
some food
he didn't answer i figured he would call
back within an hour or so so i waited
but after i sent a couple of texts and
after an hour passed with no response or
call back i decided to just go by myself
i was used to that anyway
it was at a red light at an intersection
a couple blocks down the street when it
suddenly hit me the moment i realized
for the first time that something was
actually wrong
as i sat at that intersection waiting
for the light to turn green after
staring out the driver's side window and
noticing it i quickly turned and looked
out the passenger side then my rear view
mirror in every direction i did not see
a single person or car being driven
anywhere
almost every day on my way to contract
jobs i passed through that intersection
and almost every day no matter what day
or time it contained at least some
people and some traffic my mind
attempted to run through all the
possibilities and explanations
ultimately rationalizing that there must
be or had been an event that cleared out
the area that i was not aware of
in some sense i believe i was right
about this
but not at all in the way that i thought
i anxiously continued to where i was
going to get food when i arrived the
parking lot appeared to be filled with
parked cars which quickly relieved me
but when i went in the restaurant even
though the door was unlocked there was
no one inside
not only no customers but no employees
after shouting out for someone multiple
times with no response i began to panic
i rushed back outside through the
parking lot and into the street i spun
around looking in all directions the
streets now almost fogged over with the
haze i hadn't noticed before were
completely empty
i took off running looking into cars
stores restaurants and any other
buildings i passed checking inside the
ones that were open for some reason i
yelled out pleading for anyone but no
one was anywhere to be found
i soon came to the conclusion that
something must have happened that this
part of the city must have been
evacuated or cleared out for some reason
i checked my phone for information but
it seemed to have no service i rushed
back to my apartment to check my
computer but the internet was also down
the tv and radio networks weren't live
broadcasting anything either the only
things on were a few stations playing
repeats of really old shows and movies
from maybe around 20 years ago
after briefly collecting myself i drove
into different parts of the city
different towns other cities and other
states looking for people for signs of
people for any indication or clues as to
what had happened
i found nothing
and with each new place in each new day
things seem to only get stranger and
stranger
colors seem to become less and less
saturated almost like the world was
dying
at first it was as if there was a hue of
a gloomy overcast day even while the sun
was out but then certain areas appeared
to almost become monochrome and even
stranger by this point i barely even
reacted to this
the colors of my emotions and sensations
seem to begin to dampen reflecting the
form of the monochrome dying world
around me
i was becoming numb my paranoia and
concern seemed to decrease as the
strangeness of the situation increased
pretty soon i just gave up looking for
answers turned around and drove back
home by the time i was on my drive back
entire areas and once cities off the
highway seemed to be transformed into
just massive white blocks void of any
color and texture like early stage
digital 3d renderings of architectural
designs before any of the details and
colors are added
once i returned to my apartment i
stocked up on as much food and water as
i could and stored everything in some of
the other units in my apartment building
i don't know the last time i ate or
drank anything though i don't really
feel the need to anymore and the need
seems to no longer really even be a need
[Music]
right now i sit looking out my window
watching the world continue to fade
deforming down into white textureless
blocks and more recently into a flat
white landscape lacking increasing
amounts of three-dimensional depth
it appears to be encroaching closer and
closer on me
i feel so numb
it's strange because i think the same
thoughts i've always thought but they
don't feel like thoughts it's as if my
feelings no longer understand the
language i am thinking in and it's like
hearing someone say something plainly in
another language it means it feels like
nothing
the only thing i can seem to feel is a
strange sort of longing an almost
rationalized desire to feel again
in my current state of emotionless
candor i have thought about and realized
a lot
before i woke up on that concrete
sidewalk i don't know how many times i
had thought about ending it i was ready
to let go of everything i despised most
of it
the people the things the things people
do and the things that happened to
people the way the world spun and
demanded that your head spun with it the
dissoluteness and depravity the deceit
of self of others of the world the
beliefs and the beliefs and no beliefs
the noise the chaos the fear the
uncertainty the sadness the conflict the
cruelty the difficulty the love the lack
of love the heartbreak the imaginary
goal posts constantly being moved away
from you your hopeful self still too
afraid to admit that even if you score
it won't really change the outcome of
the game the single car alarm that
sounds at just the wrong time
the thinking and the feeling
and yet now that it's almost all gone i
found myself missing it
all of it
of course i miss the colors the smells
the tastes and the simple things i liked
but also some of the same things that
made me want to no longer exist i deeply
miss now that they don't
i've realized as the world has been
chiseled down and taken away from me the
significance of each little chunk the
desire for life requires so many
undesirable aspects and what we dread is
often part of what we would miss if we
lost everything and could still be
around to know about it
in the day in and day out of existence i
got so caught up in each moment of each
experience in my singular pessimistic
myopic view i neglected to ever really
step back and realize this each piece's
significance to the whole and that the
whole is so much greater than the sum of
its parts
i think i figured out what is happening
i've mostly accepted it now
there is no other explanation
the last clear memory i have of the
world before
is me
sitting on that roof with that bottle
some decisions you can never do anything
about after you've made them
i only wish i could have seen then what
i see now
[Music]
you